so first of all it's amazing to meet you
because i'm a big fan secondly i know
you're here to talk about something else
but we've got to talk about jingle
jangle because it's very rare
i know it's april i know it's like not
even christmas time but it's very rare
to come out with a christmas movie that
could be a classic and i think like it's
a classic my kids loved it we watched it
so many times
like have you always been musical well
you know yeah i studied in music in the
first place you know so it was really a
great opportunity to get a chance to
do jingle jangle it was actually one of
the most fun movies i've ever done in my
whole career so i had a blast and
it was opportunity to get to sing again
so that was nice oh my god you
kicked ass you were so good and i love
all of a sudden i was like john legend
did all the songs he's so talented it
was so great it was
it was masterfully done i love the
costumes i love the acting i love the
cast it was just so well done i had to
start with that
because i'm a huge fan want more fun
stuff i thought so
check out these videos floating around
my head this one is really
cool i'm just saying no pressure